All right, in this section, we're gonna be talking
about ICPFX camera, SDI, timecode, and genlock.
Now, what I have on display here
is a typical wiring diagram that you'd find
in your average ICPFX facility.
It all focuses and centers around having those devices
that are gonna drive timecode and genlock.
These are critical for you.
You cannot not have these at your facility.
Typically, they'll be rack-mounted in your machine room
and they'll be either connected via wire
or even some devices can be connected wirelessly.
But for the most part,
they're gonna be wired connections to your camera,
which we showed just a little bit earlier.
It's gonna supply both timecode and genlock to your camera.
It will also, if you have any type
of video recording devices like a Q-Take system
or a Kona Field Recorder,
you'll be connecting those up,
timecode and genlock as well.
The entire mocap network that you have
will require genlock and timecode as well.
So whether you're running OptiTrack
or whether you're using some other type of brand name,
it's gonna need those particular signals
to make sure that all of your data is synchronized.
Next, you're gonna be running timecode and genlock
to your control carts and your control machines
along with your render machines.
Now, the render machines are particularly of interest here
because every render machine,
it has those two A6000 GPUs in there
that we mentioned in the past.
Those A6000 GPUs,
they are critical to making sure that they're genlocked.
So those two cards will be connected via SLI
so that they're in synchronization.
But then in addition to that,
inside of those render machines,
you need to have a Quadro II sync board.
And that Quadro II sync board will actually wire connect
to the two A6000 GPUs inside of your machine
in order to keep them in sync.
And they receive a sync signal from your timecode
and genlock devices in your machine room.
So that signal will then be daisy chained
from one render machine to the next
to make sure that all of those GPUs
are all in sync with one another
as they're being and displaying their content
through end display up on the LED wall.
Additionally, timecode and genlock
will then feed into your routing system.
So in the LA R&D lab,
we mentioned that there is an HDMI router.
These are great devices to have
in order to convert the display port signal
coming out of the A6000 card
and be able to route those video signals
to wherever they're needed within the facility.
But those signals will ultimately be routed over
to your LED processor.
Now in this particular diagram,
it's being sent to the Brompton SX40, the Tesla SX40,
but it could be an LED processor
like by MegaPixel or NovaStar
or one of these other brand names.
This video signal along with the timecode and genlock
that's being sent to it
is going to be converted
to a 10 gigabit fiber optic output.
And that will be sent video over IP
to the Brompton distribution nodes.
So these distribution nodes reside behind the wall typically
and they take that 10 gigabit signal
and break it down into multiple one gigabit
over video over IP signals.
And those connections are then daisy chain
to all the multiple panels within your ICV effects volume.
So each one of these particular devices
is critical to the whole chain
and wire flow and signal flow.
But there are ways to potentially remove certain pieces
of equipment that you could potentially do without.
For example, you could potentially
not utilize an HDMI router.
You could go directly from the rendering machines
into the Brompton processors
or into the MegaPixel processors.
That is an option.
It's not usually the best choice,
but it can work that way if that's necessary for you.
SDI and HDMI, what's the big difference?
Well, first of all, you should realize
that HDMI has some specific limitations,
namely how far of a signal it can actually transmit
without having to be augmented by some sort of booster.
SDI can run considerably longer cable lengths than HDMI.
And so SDI is the standard that we typically use
within an ICV effects volume.
Because of that, there are a number of different types
of SDI that you should be aware of.
There's HD SDI, 3G SDI, 6G SDI, and 12G SDI.
Each of these have a different bandwidth and signal rate
and are used for specific resolutions
that you might want to output to.
So as you can see on this particular slide,
HD SDI is a 720p signal,
and it's only transmitting at 1.485 gigabits per second.
Whereas a 12G SDI signal is, it's rated for 2160p
and has a 12 gigabit per second bandwidth.
So considerably more information and more resolution
is being sent on these higher class SDI signals.
Now, there's something that you should realize
when hooking up your connections to your camera.
SDI has some very specific warnings
about voltage and potential damage
that can occur to the SDI circuitry
if you hook up your camera
and your SDI devices incorrectly.
You should realize that,
just gonna take a look here in this particular slide,
Bill Bennett from the American Society
of Cinematographers writes this,
HDI, SDI vulnerability across all devices,
cameras and monitors and transmitters
in order to prevent burnout of your SDI circuitry.
When building the camera and connecting all power cables
to all accessories first,
then connect the BNC cables and do the reverse
on teardown, BNC disconnect first
and then unplug the power.
We wanna make sure that when you're setting things up
that you have a grounded electrical source
and power hooked up to the camera first.
If you don't do this
and you're trying to connect the SDI BNC cable
or power out of order,
you can potentially burn out your SDI circuitry.
It's something that I've seen happen personally.
It's not something that you wanna explain
to your director or cinematographer on stage.
So be careful when hooking up your equipment.
All right, LED hardware and processing,
we wanna talk about a little bit more about timecode.
First, what is timecode?
It's basically, it's a system and a signal
that measures time by dividing it up into smaller frames.
So timecode will synchronize the first frame
across all devices as common metadata during recording.
There's basically two types of timecode.
There's LTC, which is linear timecode.
This is basically recorded on the audio track
and it's a little bit easier to implement and use.
But then there's also VTC or vertical interval timecode.
This is where the timecode is actually embedded
into the video signal that's being recorded.
And that has some certain advantages.
There's advantages and disadvantages to both.
Linear timecode doesn't allow you to basically scrub
through the recorded signal where vertical timecode can
and the linear timecode is recorded,
like I said, onto the audio track.
So you have to consider devoting
one of those audio tracks to LTC.
If you look at the devices that we have hooked up
in your facility, you're gonna have a house generator
for both your timecode and for your genlock.
There are basically two different flavors here
of devices that you can utilize.
Again, if you have a dedicated facility,
I recommend the house generator.
And I'm gonna show you what we have over here
in the latte stage.
So if you take a look over on the latte stage here,
this is our house timecode and genlock generator.
It is basically rigged into a number
of the different potential features
and functions of our facility.
And you can see that there are a number
of different connections, B and C connections on the back.
Each of these different wired connections
are going to different devices,
like in this particular case,
this is the OptiTrack MoCap timecode connection.
And these wired connections also will go over to,
as mentioned, the Tessera.
We're a little out of focus here.
Sorry about that.
There we go.
The Brompton processors, the Tessera SX40,
which we have here.
And as also mentioned, wired connections
will also go over to your camera
and to your various control machines.
Now, if you can't afford a house generator like that,
or you're running a more independent solution,
you can use more smaller modular timecode generators.
The Tentacle Sync device is a good option here.
This allows you to hook up to various other cameras
or recorders or any other types of devices
that may not have a dedicated BNC connection.
What's nice about these is that one
of the Tentacle devices can act as a master
and can synchronize to all the other devices
through the use of an iOS device,
like an iPhone.
And this is a great way to potentially offer timecode
and have it wirelessly synchronize all of these devices
without having to have a dedicated wired house generator.
All right, we talked about the process of jamming timecode.
I just want to give a dedicated slide for this,
just so that you can see it.
So some devices only have a timecode connection port
and may lack the necessary BNCs that you'll need.
So every camera, at least every high-end camera,
has its own internal clock.
So that clock can be synchronized with your house timecode
by doing the process of jamming timecode.
That's basically where you hook up the BNC connection
to the timecode port on the back of your camera
and allow the signal to synchronize with the house clock.
Then the camera clock and your timecode clock
will be at the same time.
So it's at that point,
you can disconnect the timecode signal from the camera
and you can then hook up genlock.
If you're, like I said, on the Blackmagic Ursa,
it has both a reference in and a timecode in,
but it's on a single port.
You can just swap and exchange these
as we demonstrated earlier.
The thing to keep in mind with this is,
is that some of the internal clocks on the cameras
can drift over time.
And if that happens, you should make it a regular practice
of jamming timecode multiple times throughout the day,
probably right when you get in to your facility
in the morning, probably once at lunch
and maybe once in the afternoon.
That way you'll ensure that the clock within the camera
stays in sync with your house timecode.
All right, we're gonna continue on
and start talking about the process of jamming timecode.
We demonstrated this a little bit earlier,
but I just wanna show the slide
to make sure that you fully understand the process.
So if your camera has only a single BNC connector
that handles reference in and timecode,
you're gonna have to do the process of jamming timecode.
So every camera, every professional camera
will typically have an internal clock.
And that internal clock is very accurate
and capable of receiving a timecode signal.
And the process of jamming timecode
is essentially hooking up the BNC connector
to the timecode port in,
allowing the internal clock of the camera
to synchronize with the house timecode.
And then you unplug the timecode cable
and replace it with the genlock cable.
At that particular point in time,
it'll switch over to genlocking the camera
and your timecode will still be in sync.
Now, to be fair, some cameras will drift over time.
Some cameras don't drift very much.
Some cameras drift a lot.
It just depends on the maker and manufacturer.
So recommended practice would be
when you come into your facility in the morning,
you jam timecode, get the camera clock in sync
with your house timecode,
and then jam timecode again, say at lunch,
and then maybe once later in the afternoon.
This will help accommodate for any potential drift
in the camera clock
and keep you in sync with your house timecode.
All right, we're gonna keep going
and we're gonna start talking about genlock.
Genlock is the other signal that you should be aware of
that's critical for your operations and ICD effects.
So what is genlock?
It too is a common technique where the video output
of one source is used as a timing signal
to synchronize the drawing of all the picture sources
within your facility, pixel by pixel, line by line.
We want everything to be drawn together.
This helps prevent delay and drift
between various sources.
So genlock was a technique that was developed
early in the broadcast situation
where various cameras needed to be in sync with one another
when switching with a camera switcher.
There are basically two different types of genlock signals.
Number one, there is the black burst signal.
This is the older type of signal.
And you can see that there's the waveform vector
up at the top.
Black burst signal is only capable of handling genlock
in two frame rates, 30 frames per second
or 60 frames per second.
So keep that in mind.
The second type of signal is the tri-level sync
genlock signal.
This is for newer devices and can support more alterations
to frame rate.
It'll support 24p along with 2997, 30, 60, et cetera.
Most modern cameras can receive a genlock signal
from either black burst or from tri-level sync,
but it would be recommended that you use
a more modern device, especially for faster frame rates,
variable frame rates and higher resolutions.
Okay, now, when we're talking about genlock,
this is again something that you should be aware of.
Genlock is particularly required within an LED volume
in order to keep everything drawing in sync up on the wall.
And you can see by this particular slide here,
what happens if you are not in genlock.
So your entire LED wall is typically being rendered
by a number of different nodes,
especially if you have a very large wall.
You could have potentially up to five
or six different nodes rendering different sections
of the wall.
If those nodes aren't within end display,
if those nodes aren't synchronized via genlock,
you'll start to see what's happening here.
The ball in the bouncing demonstration there
will start to split and this is not what you want.
In order to prevent this, we deploy the Quadro II card
and you can see that's an image of what it looks like.
It sits and resides inside of your rendering machines
and it has connectors across the top
that hook into ports on your A6000 or A5000 cards
within your computer.
This will then inform the graphics card of when to draw.
And you can also see on the backside of the card
that there are some ethernet connections.
Those ethernet connections,
along with the coax connection there,
it will transmit your genlock signal
that you've hooked up into the card via a BNC connector
and then it will route that genlock signal
via an ethernet port connection to all remaining cards
within your facility.
So you need to have this set up to make sure
that all of your render devices
are in sync with one another.
Latency, this is an issue that occurs
and a lot of people have a lot of concern over it.
It's how fast your ICV effects wall
will actually display information
and how well it responds to camera movement,
tracking and processing of all of your mocap data
and anything else that's being fed
into the system via Unreal.
So there are a number of different things
that can potentially influence latency within the system.
Now at the NAND and L-A-R-N-D stage,
we have a latency of approximately seven frames,
which is pretty good.
Now here at the Latte Lab,
our latency is actually more like around probably 11 frames,
which is starting to become rather undesirable,
but we only have one render node
rendering everything for our particular wall.
So let's take a look at these items
and what contributes to latency.
One, camera tracking delay.
So we talk about having an OptiTrack system
in this particular facility.
All the data from those cameras you're tracking,
whether you're tracking the tracking mind on the camera,
all that data has to be processed in Motive
and then Motive has to send
a camera tracking solution into Unreal.
So there's a certain amount of time
and processing that that takes to occur.
Second, when it gets into Unreal,
Unreal has to take it, understand it
and apply it to the virtual camera inside of Unreal.
Then there's the issue of actually rendering out
what's in your scene.
So your GPU performance will come into a factor there,
whether you're using A6000 cards
or potentially something slower like A4000 or A5000 cards
or earlier cards like the Quadro 6000 RTX,
there's a number of different cards
that can be used in ICV effects volume.
So you wanna have the fastest GPU possible.
Second, video signal routing and conversion.
All of the different converters
that you may have in your facility,
whether you're converting the video signal
out of your camera,
or you're converting the video signal
out of your graphics cards,
all of these particular devices,
if you're trying to convert their signal,
may add a little bit of delay
in that conversion process.
So be aware of that.
Next, the LED processing and scaling.
Everything that's coming out of Unreal
and out of your render nodes
are gonna be going to these Brompton
or megapixel processors.
These LED processors have to do a certain amount
of processing of the information
and scaling the visual signal.
And that takes a little bit of time.
Then it has to convert everything over
to 10 gigabit ethernet
and transmit it over to the distribution units,
which are feeding the actual panels themselves.
So that transmission time factors into latency.
And then finally, when that particular signal
coming from the distribution nodes
are hitting the individual panels,
the panels have to draw the image itself.
So all of this adds up.
Now, there is a way to potentially turn on
a low latency mode for some of these processors,
like the Brompton has the ability
to turn on a low latency mode
in which it will sacrifice a certain amount of accuracy
in the shadow regions
in order to potentially draw the image faster.
Now, the low latency mode may save you
about one frame per second.
So if you are a little bit on the sluggish side,
you could turn that on
and it might give you a little bit better performance.
Finally, you have the issue of the camera,
its particular shutter,
how fast you're moving the camera
and the frame rate in which you're shooting at.
If you're shooting at 24 frames per second,
seven frames of delay is considerable.
You will feel it just a little bit.
But if you're shooting at higher frame rates,
that seven frames of delay won't be as noticeable.
So tracking system and options.
Just so that you are all familiar,
we've been talking about
all these different tracking solutions
inside of the ICD effects volume.
There's the OptiTrack system using Motive software.
That's what we have here at the Latte stage
and at the LA R&D stage.
But you can use certainly a number
of other different solutions
like the Shogun solution, the Vicon.
This is another alternative that works very well.
You can also, for more independent productions,
you can use the Vive system.
They have their Mars solution that works great.
You can also use just your Vive base stations
and tracking pucks as another option as well.
All three of these will suffice,
but you're probably gonna wanna be using
either the OptiTrack or the Vicon solution
for professional uses.